one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday hope
everybody's having a great day thus far
I am you are
my leg kind of hurts oh how hard for you
yeah my leg really really hurts turdy's
going through a tough time you guys yeah
just like 30 down 30 down 30 out yeah
and I'm actually not having a great day
today I'm leaving I know there's a
somber energy that's come over the house
dare I say a great Cloud so mentally and
physically strained strained strained
yeah and I'm like racing home to get to
my book club it's gonna be so chaotic
but you finished your book I finished my
book yeah I haven't read it in so long
because I'm still 50 through a court of
thorns and Roses acotar yeah because I
can't remember what it stands for and I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to
finish it because soon I have to start
reading for the redheads and we're
reading the fourth Wing which is similar
to Avatar but I think better because I
haven't heard one complaint Sal word
about fourth wing
so I don't know what's gonna happen
between acotar and I
yeah but I really just want to finish it
just to finish it just like you know
check it off the good read your yeah so
towards your account like I put 50 in
now you have to finish it I have to get
50 out get to work
I guess so I just haven't picked up my
Kindle since I gave birth I hadn't
picked up my Kindle all month like until
I had to read for book club it just like
wasn't a big reading month maybe I need
to switch to a smaller Kindle right now
maybe it's like the idea of a holding
Charles and my big ass Kindle subscribe
they're two heavy items yeah no it's
definitely a Sophie's Choice it's very
much not yeah it's very much not who had
a choice oh irina's Choice that's a good
that's when you have good choices oh
Irene is Shake yeah yeah yeah that's two
good choices okay so that's like kind of
the opposite of a deandra's choice yeah
irina's Choice like a an embarrassment
of riches exactly so I guess between a
Kindle and a baby I have an irina's
Choice oh
and for me between you know being here
with you and Bruno and being home with
Theo that's also an irina's Choice it is
if you look at the world through the
lens of Irina
laughs about Joy laughs about pain
speaking of Bruno he's here today
speaking of Bruno he is here today and
he is providing his mommy with some very
necessary body heat let's talk about
what's going on in your studio like the
icicles forming on the edge of my
nipples are real it's one degree in this
place it's so cold it's colder than it's
ever been and it's been cold all week
it's always cold because as we discussed
podcasting is a physical sport 100 not
an Olympic sport but it should be so
when people ask that Claudia do you work
out yeah yeah I podcast daily sometimes
twice sometimes Thrice sometimes Vlog
sometimes Vlog sometimes
yeah actually this is a vlog too
technically we Vlog every day we're so
like we're on camera correspondents
we're literally like famous we're just
famous you know we're just constantly on
camera we're famous so is bro so what I
was gonna say yeah was that Bruce
providing his mommy with some really
necessary how nice I mean you're the one
wearing a big old sweatshirt like I'm
over here freezing well I could bestow
upon me of something I'd like you that
you want where I I looked before there
was a blanket I didn't see it you guys
it's one degree give me that why have
you been hiding it I just didn't want to
lean over oh having a cramp oh
oh thank you you're welcome we had such
a gorgeous night last night like it's
really fun living in a house isn't it
because like of course you could do the
same things that you do in an apartment
in an apartment like read spend time
with family eat watch TV but in a house
where like should we read outside you
know there's just like different places
different Nooks to do your favorite
activities so last night we decided to
eat ice cream and watch TV
in Jackie's room
it was delightful it was it was really
cozy and sweet and Bruno was there of
course of course in Charles and Charles
Harry was already sleeping that's why
like it was like what's the point but we
were watching Magnolia table and it was
thundering and lightning like crazy such
a good vibe it was such a good vibe and
I'm loving watching Magnolia table like
that's my content Vibe right now cooking
shows but as we've discovered over the
last few days there's really a gap in
the market for cooking shows they kind
of all stuck well this is what we've
been talking about Joe this is what
we've been talking about for decades
like this shift at the Food Network to
competition shows baking bake offs like
they don't make just classic women on
camera in her kitchen type of shows
anymore yeah it's always got an edge of
course we could go back and watch the
old episodes because they used to make a
million of them but now watching content
from like 15 years ago it's not premium
yeah let me tell you what's wrong with
all of them Barefoot Contessa her
camera's blurry like literally there's a
millionaire 20 years ago at this point
and honestly the recipes are like too
fast-paced it's like I want to relax I
want to watch you do the whole process
they're not fast-paced in my opinion
they're not good like it's just not what
I would want to eat that's also a
problem because Joanna Gaines mostly
cooks for her kids I find myself like
every episode there's something I would
eat there you know yeah and then we
watched Rachel Ray last night and I hate
to speak ill of Queen Rachel Ray because
she's actually someone I deeply admire
and respect but her cooking show is
chaos like it's and I understand why she
you know she's under the gun it's 30
minute meals she's making a meal for her
family there's a gun to her head and you
know what she hasn't hit that 30 minutes
she's not hiding it well like she's
panicked everything is running jumping
scraping like it's not relaxing to watch
whatsoever and Jackie warned me she's
like you're not gonna like Rachel Ray
she's a chaos machine and I'm like you
don't know Rachel like I know her
Claudia I'm having Deja Vu because
literally years ago on the toast we have
this conversation I had this
conversation I was telling you about how
Rachel Ray is chaotic and you're like no
no because you love her and you like I
have like a weird speak so highly of her
I think I like have fond memories of
like watching her I think she had 30
minutes minute meals was always on a
Grammy's house okay like and I just
remember like laying in those big
leather chairs like I feel a Nostalgia
to Rachel and I do I'm not ashamed of
that okay but you just are constantly
defending her and it's funny because you
literally sound like me for verbatim if
someone could go and find that clip or
if you just watched it recently while we
were on Hiatus like I literally am
talking about how Rachel Roy is chaotic
in her 30 minute meals congrats no it's
just like we're simpatico congrats worse
it's me saying you said it first add it
to the last that's not what I was saying
I certainly will but that's not what I
was saying well it doesn't change the
fact that Rachel Ray like is chaos no it
doesn't but that's just like you missed
my whole point congratulations
congratulations
oh she's annoying today congratulations
she's annoying this mama got up and
there's three times to sit with I got
him too like I got him too I'm not in my
own home I'm using like trash CBS makeup
like I'm I'm here too what happened to
your makeup that I got from Olivia's I
my you know what's do you notice this in
the like the different temperatures here
does your makeup like
in Florida like feel different when you
put it on than in New York no like
everything I have in my makeup kit like
my foundation's like chunky Everything
feels like it's like separating it just
feels like different climate like it's
affecting how the makeup sits in its
tubes do you not think it's because it's
old like it's six months to a year old
it's all my makeup is like old like I
don't buy like everything new like I use
things forever yeah and it's not like
that old and so especially like I keep
buying new stuff I just feel like when I
put on makeup here it's different that's
interesting I haven't had that
experience and I had like my New York
makeup and my Florida makeup when I came
back I've been using both and I haven't
noticed a difference so I on that we're
not simpatico I just feel like it's like
chunky is it possible like with the
climate but like your house is so cold
like this is so cool surprised my makeup
doesn't have like icicles I can't blame
the climate no I can't I just feel like
I don't know something's a mess
I think maybe it's old but it's not like
every time I'm here I go buy new makeup
like from where from everywhere like
whatever I went when I went to the mall
like I'm always like you know keeping my
kit fresh okay yeah I'm sorry you're
going through that it's been tough and
Rachel Ray's been no help but Joanna has
that was the point we landed like Joanna
Gaines is really kind of the only
cooking show worth watching like we've
done the research yeah so you don't have
to we kind of need more new cooking
shows we need more women in the kitchen
and that's back into the kitchen that's
what I've been saying for years like
women belong in the kitchen could you
imagine marketing a cooking show by it
man yeah like Emerald Mario is not the
vibe what's his name Mario badali
badescu no he's canceled Mario badescu
is makeup it's canceled and Mario Batali
yeah he had some scandal at his
restaurant I thought on his show
no I think it was like Steph from his
restaurant yeah it was staff from his
restaurant but he was also on a show
like a morning show about food like
today The Chew or something and he was
doing stuff damn that I have no idea
what that stuff is I'm just saying
because I haven't followed there have
been men chefs no no I'm I I can
recognize you both I know what we're
about saying the kitchen is a place for
a woman and I don't want to watch a man
on TV in the kitchen yeah I just think
like if you have hairy Knuckles like you
really shouldn't you shouldn't be
needing my dad joke you get your hands
out of my food like get your hands on my
food with your hairy knuckles I totally
agree so writing and cooking are for the
girls leave it to the women yeah
and we'll see what else is for the women
as we continue on with today's show
yes we shall this has been a rough week
for stories
it has it I mean I chose him like two
days and I maybe I actually just don't
like choosing the stories it's a lot of
pressure maybe that's it heavy it's the
head that chooses the story yeah but I
feel like for me I'm always concerned
like I want our episodes to be long and
like full of good tangents and stuff so
if I'm choosing the stories that usually
means you're not here and if I'm
choosing the stories like if you're
choosing the stories the other person
like doesn't know like the story is like
a launch pad like we don't have to talk
about the story like let's talk about
ourselves right so if they don't
recognize that like I'm just left with
this crap story yeah and you have to
treat it like a real story right but if
it's like a gorgeous story me and the
co-host could talk about it endlessly
but I just like I need people to like
get the with the program like the
stories are just like a merely a
launching pad for us to dive into other
topics like you know whatever that may
be so that's why I personally hate using
the story it's like if you choose a bad
story like we're gonna find a way to
talk about it whatever matter because it
doesn't affect the lane you know that
it's not about the stories here and it's
never bit about the stories here never
that's why they're the Fast Five we're
trying to get them over I can't get
through them quick enough sometimes like
yesterday like dark times really dark
times but I'm not concerned with the
length so much I get concerned with the
length of the show just because of ad
placement like it's a formula right that
is on your plate right and so when both
things are on my plate I'm panicked it's
a lot for one place that's why when I'm
back at the studio in New York I
pre-record my ads
yeah that's fine just so I can play some
and really just be in the moment with my
co-hosts
also I'm having Carpe Diem Carpe Diem
season for the day I'm headed
back to New York today and I have
literally nothing scheduled because I
canceled everyone and everything for
Thursday and Friday because I thought I
would be here forever so I've
rescheduled everyone and we've really
good couple of weeks coming up but
Thursday Friday this week I'm not sure
well I'll do Friday Okay so Thursday
Taylor's tracker what if I just called
Taylor up was you just call Taylor up
and that's exactly what I'm gonna do
love that so we've got a great show
because it's Wednesday which means it's
dear toasters day dear toasters is our
weekly advice segment on Wednesdays we
how about the girlies we tell them get
back in the kitchen girl what are you
doing out here in the conference room
life is just so much simpler if we stay
in the kitchen you know what like I'm
joking but I'm dead serious no when I
watch these cooking shows it's like why
did we ever leave yeah it's like the
fact that Joanna even though it's
unrealistic at this point in her life
that she's like making gourmet dinners
for her kids every single night
appetizer entree and dessert like she's
literally making taco night on a cake
and a tres leches cake but like there
was a time when like you know if the
kids are off at school what am I doing
this afternoon I'm making a three-course
meal yeah but no instead I'm working I'm
podcasting no and the thing is when I
look at like a woman in the kitchen on
TV it's like idyllic but but Joanna
Gaines like is probably it's like the
opposite of a woman in a kitchen she
runs like a billion dollar business like
right yeah here she is in the kitchen
right makes you think like no matter how
far we come we're always just gonna be
back in the kitchen but it's a nice
place to be it is it is but watching her
was making my back hurt mostly because
my back hurts but there is an expiration
on how long I can stand in the kitchen
of course
same and I didn't just give birth like
yeah I can't I'm really I was just
telling you my legs hurt like I can't be
like that active I look forward to the
day when I'm not like
on a clock of like when until my back
breaks yeah yeah you look at the 10
standing minutes 20 standings you'll get
there yeah it's just painful and I want
to get back in the kitchen of course
Where I Belong where are you literally
go I know well Joanna made this lasagna
yeah and you know she did it in a dutch
oven so she didn't have to like the
torture of lasagna is like making your
noodles layering she just Stir It All in
This pot well that's the beauty of a
lasagna it really is a one-pot dish but
it requires a lot of work before it's in
one pot right but I love a one pot dish
and a lasagna is a casserole they say
yep not the way she made it because she
made it in the Dutch oven instead of a
casserole dish
true but could you make a casserole in a
dutch oven yum
but then it wouldn't be a casserole
really what makes a casserole dish
the dish
but what's what are the specks of a
casserole dish what would you say is
your favorite dish
um a mug
that's like one of my favorite moments
to cite in pop culture history and I
wonder if Dimitri Lovato truly knows
like was she in on the joke when she
said that
like this can imagine like someone who's
so talented and singing wise could be
like that funny yeah but the thing is
like the person interviewing her I think
she was doing like foreign television so
maybe Demi was just like lost in like I
think she was awesome there's no way
because it's literally so funny yeah and
she said like she was spitting facts
like she loves a bug like it keeps your
drinks hot and she was not wrong for
that what's your favorite dish which
kind of dish
kitchenware kitchenware and like I guess
dish like for eating
as opposed to like for cooking because
that feels like two different questions
my favorite dish
like I don't know I don't cook but I
guess the dish I make chili in which is
my Dutch oven oh okay and dish for like
eating
Before It's Your go-to Vessel a fork
like a bowl like a bowl oh oh I see your
question
um I don't know it really difficult no
you know what it is it is
what do you mean F4 is a dish
my brain hurts and
to answer your question my favorite dish
is a paper plate
like that's my favorite way to consume
like a sandwich or something factual
that was one of the more like brain
numbing conversations we've had I hope
you guys actually made it through that
to hear the rest of this episode because
there's going to be a lot of smart
things that happen in this episode and
you won't want to miss them this episode
is she you know this should be titled
smartless
because like we're being dumb we're less
smart and maybe it'll like confuse
people who are looking for the by the
way we're naming today's episode and
maybe it'll get the attention of the
smartless guys I'm like we're over here
but I don't want to get their attention
on this episode yeah they're like wow
those two girls are morons and they
complain they're not number one okay but
we are gonna call today's episode
tomorrow or less like just because I
think Wednesday's episodes always do
really well if it wasn't another podcast
called smartless like that should be the
title of this episode it's appropriate
because we're being dumb
I have to say less smart
equals dumb
so glad we settled that should we dive
in Girlfriend yes without further Ado
About our favorite dishes it is time for
the fast five stories that you maybe or
maybe not need to know I'm gonna go with
maybe not today no I think no they're
not actually not bad because you never
know what else you'll find out in
between the stories also like if you
made it through yesterday's stories like
you'll be fine life is about reading
between the stories
I love that look at your finger be
closer to my face I mean get a bigger
Studio like I'm gonna go across
[Music]
am I that close do it to me
oh yeah like I could see your whole nail
okay more dumb
today's episode really is dumb
okay well this is a dumbass episode
maybe it's time for us to go back to the
kitchen
maybe the Working World maybe our work
here is done well
this dumbass episode keep reaching for
my iPad I have it my Phantom iPad
today's episode is brought to you by
Lulu La man all right Lululemon they've
got everything in them you can't see it
because I'm wearing these pants because
it's freezing in the studio today but
I'm wearing lemon pants so am I I'm
wearing the um a line flare pant you
can't see because I'm wearing the
biggest blanket so they have so much
Lululemon that's worth speaking about
but most importantly I think they're
fast and free leggings that are powered
by new Luxe fabric they provide a
weightless and body sensation and they
have incredible coverage they're
designed for those looking for a legging
that gives them a complete freedom from
distractions while running or jogging
they also have the Wonder train leggings
designed for one of Lou lemon's most
Innovative Fabrics it's called everlux
it's their fastest drying fabric so
they're Wonder train leggings allow you
to work hard and feel dry so you can
feel effortlessly and transition from
sweat to street they're great for
activities from spin
or hit uh the Align leggings which I
have been wearing for a really long time
are powered by the nulu fabric they're
designed for the person who wants a
lightweight low compression yoga
solution that is also versatile enough
for casual wear give you they give you
the uh they give the wearer excuse me a
next to nothing body sensation you have
full freedom of movement and it doesn't
restrict or compress the wearer in any
way it's great for low intensity
workouts like yoga or just casual wear
because say it with me ladies you don't
need to work out to wear workout clothes
um Blue Lemon is your One Stop Shop for
everything whether you're super active
you're getting into the active life or
you just like to walk around in
comfortable clothing that makes you feel
and look good so get into the Lululemon
leggings at lululemon.com the best
leggings hands down always Lululemon and
that's lululemon.com today's episode is
also brought to you by by Poise no sure
fine she's disrupting my flow you don't
even have your sheet no it's not brought
to you by poison it's bright did you
by the inky list okay I'll help you skin
care can be confusing and with all of
the complicated Beauty jargon it can
seem nearly impossible to figure out
what is actually best for your skin now
you don't need to figure it out on your
own shop with confidence with the inky
list the inky list is an award-winning
science-backed skincare brand that has
the right ingredients at an affordable
price to get the results that you're
looking for
whether it's targeting acne reducing
Fine Lines boosting hydration the inky
list creates a unique skin care routine
that really works so you can reach your
skincare goals if you don't know where
to start your first stop should be their
online skincare quiz they'll answer any
of your questions so you can make a
better decision about your skin like do
I really need a toner and what actually
is polyglutamic acid or is skipping
moisturizer making my oily skin worse
you can get a whole new skin routine for
under thirty dollars and if you already
know what you need you can find products
with ingredients that work like retinol
and vitamin C and you can do so without
breaking the bank and the inky list just
launched a new product that will take
your routine to the next level with
their new Plumping lip balm you can get
up to 40 off plumper lips in just four
weeks no filter no filler just Fuller
check out the before and afters on their
website if you don't believe us and if
you don't believe us like you're
disgusting right now the inky list is
offering our listeners 20 off their
purchase with promo code toast go to the
inkylist.com that's spelled i n k e y
list Dot com use promo code toast for 20
off your order that's the inky i n k e y
list.com promo code toast to check it
out get your skincare girl your skin is
looking musty and Dusty and crusty go to
thank you list.com
wow I went there are you ready I'm like
shame to convert some ads you know no
it's a new tactic let's see how it works
you know we've graduated from Jingles
right that
went over amazingly yeah
are you ready for the stories now I
guess Joe Jonas's exes Sophie Turner and
Taylor Swift step out for a girls night
amid divert divorce and diverse the
diverse devotion Sophie Turner stepped
out for a girls night with Joe's ex and
you know her friend Taylor Swift in New
York City on Tuesday night they grabbed
dinner at Via corota Turner who split
from Joe earlier this month after four
years of marriage showed off her stomach
in a plunging halter top matching pants
and sneakers
they both wore ponytails okay so nobody
cares about their ponytails everybody
was like freaking
um I hate that like we're referring like
Taylor Swift is like not Joe Jonas's ex
like that's literally someone she did in
middle school yeah it's at this point
it's a good story it's a coincidence
really because they are just friends
right and they're just like Hollywood
starlets who are hanging out really
having nothing to do it might be that
like they only know each other because
at one point or maybe they're as close
as they are because at one point in time
Taylor and Joe knew each other but like
they're really not exes like let's calm
down or do you think that they actually
would have been closer if it wasn't like
they had this Mutual no
at the time like because even like they
probably would have been friends
regardless of Joe but when it's
technically your man's ex how close are
you gonna get no it's really not your
man's ex they did when they were like
literally 17 it doesn't count
but it counts for Taylor everything
counts for Taylor no and I actually
think like her being married to Taylor's
like a high school boyfriend
is the reason they are so close because
like Taylor
obviously has made amends with Joe now I
send their babies presents and she
leaned on uh Sophie during like The
Fearless era Fearless she was like
promoting a bunch of Mr perfectly fine
so I think like they're close because
she's a Swifty but they have this like
connection and it's not weird because no
it's not weird and I don't think they
spent dinner like trashing Joe no I
actually don't even think they spoke
about it like I think she was just
trying to get her girly like out on the
town you know Positive Vibes divorce
party I'm sure they spoke about it
because it's like the biggest thing
going on in Sophie's life but Taylor
wasn't coming from a place of experience
like no like he did the same thing to me
right no like I bet she doesn't even
we're not the same they don't she
doesn't even remember the time they
spent together like seriously but you
know she does because she remembers
everything yeah oh I remember
she remembers well this was fabulous and
it did make me a little annoyed because
I was supposed to go home on Sunday and
Taylor has been out and about she was at
zero Bond via corota like I could have
been I probably would have been laying
in bed but I could have been yeah maybe
zero Bond probably not via Kuroda no I
don't know you to go there I don't
really but now I need to start
but this looks fun it does and it feels
like a choice you know it is it is and
the um paparazzi photos of them leaving
the restaurant are really cute but then
when you watch like the actual walking
out of the restaurant take place on
video it's
apocalyptic there are 5 000 people like
girls just and there's not even like a
barricade or anything they're just
standing outside the door of the
restaurant giving Taylor and Sophie like
room to walk nobody like attacked them
or anything it was the weirdest thing to
watch like the actual video yeah they
usually are it's like kind of awkward
yeah and they and really but the
pictures wind up like being fabulous
because and I've noticed this like they
walk really slow Taylor and some people
were walking really slow like hand in
hand in unison because like this is a
fabulous photo this is a great press
moment for both of them especially when
the Press has been like really mean to
Sophie recently so
they're walking like literal zombies
like so slow and intentionally yeah it
is well I hope they had fun me too what
do you like what do you think they did
afterwards like big cookies and drink
wine yeah but then why'd they go out to
dinner well maybe for this picture to be
spotted and like you know they're both
women in the in the media like they got
to be seen and what do you think about
the outfits oh let me say Oh I thought
Taylor looked very cool like I would
literally never wear this jacket but
like she looks fabulous and it's giving
you know Sophie's outfit is giving like
the big pants Trend we were talking
about recently it's not my favorite I
think it's actually terrible I think
Taylor looks amazing what do you think
I think there's elements of each outfit
that I appreciate but as a whole not my
favorite okay
but there's elements Taylor has never
been I like I love my queen would
literally lay my life hat on the line
for her she has never been been being
she has never been like the best dressed
celebrity at any moment in time yeah she
always does a good job it's never
life-changing it's never you know edgy
or daring it's just fine I wonder why
she doesn't go all the way right like
with like the best stylist don't have to
think about it I don't know but I also
think like her outfits like actually
really are a reflection of her personal
style and I just don't think her
personal style is like that crazy or
amazing yeah because like which is fine
you know which is so funny actually the
more I think about it I appreciate it
you can do the best at everything now in
all of her creativity like is channeled
into her music songwriting and I do wish
like more celebrities would dress
normals no and it's like everybody all
the time like there's some celebrities
who like just crush it and street style
is like and have like a natural brand
ability to like style themselves they
also have stylists but they also have a
natural ability to just like carry the
lady Trends yeah not talking about them
but like it is fun to see what people
would pick out their own outfit to go to
dinner with a friend right yeah
I agree like it doesn't have to be like
the most at the airport all the time
yeah like it's it's setting unrealistic
expectations for women who are supposed
to be in the kitchen right do less put
on your apron and call it a day put on
your apron in your oven mitts like
that's all you're gonna need to wear
today
are you ready for our next story yeah
Kim Kardashian has been quote hanging
out with Odell Beckham Jr
so page six is reporting that Kim and
Odell have been spending some time
quality time together in recent weeks an
Insider told page six that Kim and the
Baltimore Ravens wide receiver
on the Giants that was like a million
years ago have been hanging out casually
following his split from his girlfriend
Lola wood however sources to both Kim
and Odell tell page six to pair are
friends and have been mostly hanging out
in groups as they share a lot of mutual
acquaintances they insisted that Kim is
not seriously dating anyone at the
moment but is open to finding love again
if she meets the right person however
right now her main phone case is her
kids and her business
um I do think that he's actually like
probably a good match for her he's like
a really well respected football player
and I feel like he's a cool person too
like a lot of celebrities like him and
hang out with him so he must be like a
great guy
um I'm just kind of in like my I don't
care about Kim era do you feel like I
actually yawned when you said this story
you chose it I did oh my God I did thank
you because like I like people care I
guess but I just maybe I maybe I chose
it so I could you know get on my soapbox
and be like Kim's not doing it for me
recently okay yeah I kind of feel like
it's still in that lull yeah of
quietness and also this to me feels
really obvious like maybe they are
dating great maybe they're just friends
great right don't care either way great
it's not like an inspired different like
we could talk about it for hours and
like Kim's in a new era and trying to
make new things like Pete Davidson we
spoke about at length because it was so
crazy and I really expected that like
the next person she dates would be like
a private person yeah not a celebrity so
for her to be dating like a Charming
single celebrity who everybody loves
right who's like a eligible bachelor
yeah it's
obvious yeah
so and then also the same sources who
say they're dating and also saying
they're not dating and they're just
hanging out as friends okay well that
also is a good launching pad for me to
ask you like what do you think is going
on truly with um Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelsey because there's been like a few
updates
no confirmation of any sorts but like it
kind of feels like they're not dating
and Travis is like excited to let people
think that they are that's exactly what
it feels like also did you see that
Jason Kelsey like said they're dating
said he doesn't know what goes on
Travis's personal life but he hopes he
ends up with someone great you know yeah
they're so not dating I no I think
they're literally not dating but she'll
never come out and say that they're not
dating she just lets people say whatever
they want about her so he's like basking
in the fame and the Press I really feel
like these two people I've never met
yeah it was like when Harry jausi was
dating Khloe Kardashian like he's gonna
milk it of course eat it up these people
I would expect that from like a reality
star an influencer and podcaster I
wouldn't expect that from Travis Kelsey
but he I had said at the end of last
football season where it was like Kelsey
this Kelsey that like Travis is a little
thirsty yeah he's he's silly and he
doesn't take himself seriously which I
appreciate so he'll have fun with rumors
like this yeah I don't think he's really
trying to convince people that he's
dating Taylor but it's like oh that's
funny let me go with it and then Taylor
was wearing like a necklace she was like
going to record music and Paparazzi got
her and it was a necklace and it
happened to be like his birthstone which
is what
I don't know let me rule his birthstone
it's probably like diamond like it's
right that's what I'm saying Ruby right
like necklaces are made with different
types of stones all the time it's not a
coincidence no but there are some like
my birthstone nobody's just casually
walking around with it yellow topaz oh I
agree
so he celebrates his birthday on October
5th making it he's a Libra and opal it's
giving yellow topaz it's a little niche
what's my birthstone Ruby I think I
think so okay let's search Claudia
Ashley birthstone I'm sure it would come
up
July birthstone
is Ruby
look at these Ruby items give me
something I like this ring
even when she's working she can't stop
investing back to the kitchen from Grown
Brilliance that's a nice ring
hold on sorry my hands are not an ad my
100 gift that is a nice ring I don't
love my birthstone like what am I gonna
wear red jewelry like just be glad it's
not yellow topaz yeah show me what I
don't even know what a yellow topaz
looks like me neither it's definitely
one of the worst ones which one is
Diamond like that's not fair Margo I
think oh Margo's Emerald oh that's nice
which is a really nice one
oh it's yellow it's just yellow it's
topaz and citrine can you Diamond Burger
you just pull the list of all the
birthstones that's a good call instead
of each one we'll be here for 12 hours
but I just have to say like birthstones
get a life
random no I agree like birthstones
people who like I mean that's literally
us right now those are gonna be like
people who talk about birthstones like
get a life no but seriously get a life
like whoever noticed that Taylor Swift
was wearing a topaz or whatever it was
opal like yeah why do you know that okay
January okay Garnet oh that might be
worse than yellow topaz agreed it's just
red and it's not Ruby right February
amethyst not bad fun to say amethyst
amethyst March aquamarine that movie
saved that birthstone a hundred percent
April diamond
that's Ben
May Emerald now let me ask you a
question are these like horoscope dates
or is it all of April month okay month
which is much more palatable for me what
did you say may was Emerald
June Pearl beautiful that's nice and
Alexandrite right
I guess November has two also we'll get
to it July Ruby August Peridot but it's
pretty it's like a lime green I just
feel like July should have gotten
Diamond like if our horoscope sign is
going to be cancer but I don't think the
people who invented birthstones and
horoscopes were chatting I just think
somebody should have been you know
thinking about the people born in July
yeah
and they weren't they weren't September
Sapphire gorgeous gorgeous
October opal and tourmaline which is
pink cute tourmaline yeah you know that
yeah how I don't know I never heard of
it I have
what do you like want to congratulate me
one keep going congrats November
congrats
November oh my God our camera's not
recording yes it is gotcha
gotcha
November yellow topaz and citrine
citrine sometimes when you cleaned your
sink with we have two yellow Stones
Yellowstone
yellow size Yellowstone
and December blue topaz and blue zircon
kinata zirconia they have two blue
stones so
it definitely feels like this should be
oh excuse me it definitely feels like
the distribution of a good
birthstones like is not
Fair yeah but it's just like there's
only a handful of great Stones Diamond
Emerald Sapphire Ruby Pearl
aquamarine
now you like pearls right
do I I feel like you do I feel like
you've been wearing pearls recently I
haven't
I know what conversation we're talking
about like you and I were but no you
were like looking for a set of pearls no
I bought a necklace that was made of
pearl remember
no I'm picking it up next week
remember I made a big investment I told
you about yeah yeah yeah but that's
actually not what I'm talking about if
we're looking for a set of pearls no I
really complete your like classy look no
I think like a pearl necklace is like
the weirdest thing like oh you're still
on that yeah okay so I won't add it to
the list yet yeah no not yet
are you ready for our next story what
number three Tres Leches Tesla
cheesecake
yeah Vanna White extends her wheel a
fortune contract through the 2025-2026
season Vanna White has extended her
contract on Wheel of Fortune by two
years as the show begins its farewell
season with long time host Pat Sajak
than a housing to contract extension
that keeps her revealing letters on the
durable syndicated game show through
2025 to 2026 Pat announced earlier this
year his plans to retire Ryan Seacrest
will be taking on WE forgotten that it
was Ryan Seacrest and then there were a
lot of questions about will than uh
Brian into the new era it should really
be have we said this that it should be
Julianne Hoffman Ryan Seacrest No it
should be like she'll Sasha Airway
across that thing yeah to the letters
and they could fall in love again yeah
it's like a will they won't they right
that's what it's really always been like
for you think Nana and Pat ever
for sure it's Hollywood it's Hollywood
baby like definitely but this is
interesting because there were a lot of
questions like and I think also people
felt like Vanna maybe Vanna should have
Pat's job like no I think people were
also feeling like that'll give it up
because also I had heard that like Pat
Sajak's daughter was like a pageant
Queen who was like in the running for
the next Mana position well she'll just
have to wait till 2026. so that I said
hold my letters I'm going back but
I also feel like Vanna drove a hard
bargain because she brings a lot of the
old time legitimacy to the show and if
if everything is all new then it will be
ruined like everything else that's all
new yes but also like rip off the
Band-Aid you know we're changing
Pat like just switch it up
I I don't think so I feel like they do
that all the time or they're like we
want young and fresh and everybody
you're fired yeah and it turns to
so I think like this slow roll out and
eventually Vanna can go but I think her
being there to show Ryan the ropes
and let viewers know like the show's not
changing too much because you have to
think of the viewers of the show and
they're not gems no they're not they're
not watching in between Renegades I
[Music]
I feel like people look at that in a way
and they're like that's such an easy job
I you know anyone could do it and to be
honest I can't think of a job I'd like
less like standing in heels for hours
like we see 30 minutes but they shoot so
many episodes back to back we don't see
them cutting we don't see them resetting
the lights she has to be like perfect
posture perfect smile on her face my God
like that actually sounds horrible yeah
what about when van is having a hard day
what about what Vanna wants what about
what Vanna needs well she definitely got
a nice Hefty contract and we'll see her
through 2025 to 2026. she's like a
really good level of celebrity in the
sense that she has like household
recognition like she's
everybody knows her name and like if I
start at the grocery store I probably
wouldn't recognize her and I certainly
wouldn't ask for a picture if I did
recognize her yeah but you wouldn't
would you ask for a picture with like
Taylor if you saw her
well that's like you I can't answer that
question it's just like a simple yes or
no it's like
use someone else
Kim yeah like I'd ask him for a picture
like I'm hell-bent on becoming friends
with Taylor Swift which is why like I
don't think I could really ask her for a
picture okay also Maggie say Jack the
daughter will continue being a social
media correspondent for the show okay
start somewhere yeah
yeah butter
I mean yeah but you know what you got to
turn the letters nepotism is unless it's
bring your daughter to work day is so
Hollywood is so Rife with an appetism
like it's even taking on Wheel of
Fortune yeah for sure I mean she is the
social media correspondent no and I just
want to say like I'm here for it that's
nepotism that doesn't bother me as long
as she's good at the job yeah
um speaking of job get to work oh so now
I can speak yep okay well today's
episode is brought to you by Poise you
guys because here at the toast we love
Poise Ultra thins becoming a mom has
come with a lot of big changes and
especially with baby number two I'm
experiencing some of that all over again
you know the joys of postpartum life
everything from my water breaking to
post birth recovery to you know this
some sneeze here and there oh Poise
Ultra thins gets me through something
super common that we don't always talk
about when it comes to the postpartum
life is bladder leaks one in two women
over 20 experience bladder leaks and
most young moms try to use period pads
to solve the problem but I bet you
didn't know this period pads aren't
designed for pee and the absorption is
different for period Tings and pee Tings
interesting and that's just something I
know as a woman in stem thankfully Poise
Ultra fins are specifically designed for
bladder leaks and they keep you 10 times
drier than the leading pad the Clean dry
and fresh protection these pads provide
is a lifesaver and they're shaped to fit
and flex with your body so you can stay
comfortable and live without compromise
Poise Ultra thins offer with and without
wings so you can live worry free Claudia
is an anti-wing person I don't like
wings I like wings and personally I have
enough on my plate as a mum so I love
the idea of taking one worry off the
list it takes Poise learn more at
poise.com
p-o-i-s-e today's episode is also
brought to you by JS Health vitamins JS
Health vitamins is a science focused
vitamin and wellness brand that provides
targeted formulas to help you meet your
personal health goals it was created
using the highest quality ingredients
and it is back to buy research
it's made in Australia and it's created
by expert nutritionist Jessica sepel JS
Health vitamins have a formula for all
of your needs whether that's skin
digestion Street sleep sleep stress hair
growth and more Aussies are globally
renowned for their High supplement
standards and it really shows with these
vitamins so the detox and deep bloat is
their tried and true Global bestseller
it's designed to reduce bloating and
support natural detoxification processes
and based on traditional use the vegan
friendly friendly formula contains a
unique blend of carefully selected
ingredients including turmeric milk
thistle and fennel add a research back
to supplement dose to support liver
function and promote healthy digestion
this is a Formula that can honestly give
you comfort and confidence very quickly
um and the Magnesium is another one of
their products that's one of their best
sellers it's Advanced magnesium from JS
Health vitamins they contain three forms
of bioavailable magnesium it's carefully
designed to support muscle relaxation
energy production and nervous system
function all of their this is just a
brand that you can trust they have
really high standards the ingredients
are made really well and it's backed by
science so check out their website get
your vitamins like together girlfriend
go to jshealthvitamins.com toast that's
letter J letter S Health vitamins.com
toast and make sure to use kotos for 20
off your order
um of your first subscription order so
that's code toast for 20 off your order
or first subscription order thank you JS
Health we need to get a second iPad down
here like this flipping and flopping
isn't working for me I like to share
with my girl you said she could share it
like Kayla we it makes this have to be
more in sync you know true like more
connected on the same page our next
story Bijou Phillips requests spousal
support from Danny Masterson in prison
as divorce stocks indicate the X's has
no prenup so you're divorcing Bijou foul
for divorce and she's asking for spousal
support in her divorce from her husband
Danny Masterson after he was recently
sentenced to 30 years to life in prison
in his rape re-trial the actress filed
for divorce on Monday after nearly 12
years of marriage and requested to
terminate the Court's ability to Grant
support to Masterson with whom she
shares a nine-year-old daughter
she requested that she be granted full
legal and physical custody of the
daughter while Masterson be given
visitation rights She also asked that
their assets be divided up by the court
as separate property with no indication
in the papers that the access had a
prenup in place she cited irreconcilable
differences as the reason for their
split well that's putting it mildly I
just wonder why you would like stick
with your man
during the trial if only just to get
divorced well maybe it's like okay
you're spending the next 30 Years to
life in prison like there's no more
marriage here you know what if I want to
like move on with my life get remarried
like I'll still come and visit you who
knows I have no idea what's actually
going on but like
if your man's gonna be behind bars well
yeah there's a question Zach's behind
bars for 30 years and let's say like
let's take the crime out of it because
of course like if somebody did some
exactly something abhorrent like you
would leave him because of that right
but it does take the crime out of it
like Zach is going to prison for 30
years 30 to life I thought let's say 30.
okay 30. so in 30 years and but also
these people are older than us right
right they're like 40 right so what are
you doing
but I'm talking about at this current
moment I really couldn't say I really
couldn't say either
man I would like to think like Ben would
want me to move on you know like just to
make the decision easier for me yeah
yeah or or I'd be like listen I will
come visit you
I will like write to you bringing you
care packages fill up your commissary
like I will be there for you we could
stay married yeah but like a girl's
gotta eat like no no like
you will never know like what was it
doing on the outside will never affect
how I'm treating you on the inside yeah
like I need to go out on dates and like
I mean we can't go on dates when like
you're legally married to someone
because that's like a lot of baggage for
the person that you're dating
no but like I would stay legally married
oh
and be like listen this could work out
we we can only be together for 30 years
that's what I and what's bad yeah that's
longer than most marriages right
so I'm feeling like maybe it's to do
with that like she's really they're
never gonna be able to be married again
right hence divorce also I don't
understand like he was really he was
accused of such heinous crimes like to
Stand By Your Man like that like is she
obviously like believed that he did not
do such things right so she thinks he's
an innocent man in prison and she's
going to divorce him like it's just not
adding up one plus one is equaling sock
yeah also what doesn't what confuses me
she's requesting full legal and physical
custody of their daughter what no the
daughter's gonna live in the prison like
duh duh right I'm so not a lawyer no but
this seems it just definitely seems like
Superfluous language right yeah
yeah for sure
tough staff do do you know Bijou
Phillips I don't I mean I only know her
now they both have fun names to say I
love saying Danny Masterson do you yeah
say it like that Denny Masterson
um I didn't know her before I know her
now is like the halloumi tune stood by
Danny Masterson but I I don't know if
she was like a star before she might
have been yeah she's here on like a step
in repeat in front of a Netflix like
stepping repeat let me see I don't know
what she looks like really
okay is it just me or do they look like
brother and sister like they literally
actually no no they look like brother
and sister no they seriously do maybe
that's like kind of another element of
what we can Claudia you can't understand
they look exactly alike exactly except
for hair and facial hair but like if you
swapped it if you look past like his
beard they're twins I wouldn't be
surprised if they seriously were from
the same room oh yeah the more you look
no I know the more it is
and like they say that people who are
married start to like look alike but
only two people who know them right
right you have to like know them for a
long time and then you see them and
maybe it's just because they're smiling
the exact same way in this photo no they
have the same eyes they're related
they're literally twins
mm-hmm
oh
bye
next story yeah our fifth and final
because there's a new Doc view series
out on Apple TD plus called the
supermodels okay have you heard about
this no following Cindy Crawford Naomi
Campbell Linda Evangelista and Chrissy
Turlington and they reflect on how they
came to dominate the fashion industry so
a lot of headlines coming out about some
of the tidbits outside today Cindy
Crawford said something about Oprah yes
she called out Oprah for treating her
like chattel by demanding she show up
her body on camera at age 20 to prove
that she was worthy of fame
um but there's a lot of different
headlines from the show that are coming
forward about like I mean these girls I
came of age very young 90s crazy is it a
reality show or like a documentary
documentary got it where I think
everyone's like sitting down and telling
their story I don't know what the you
know thesis is of the show but it's
definitely fascinating you know actually
I like that idea it kind of reminds me
of that iconic e-show with Olivia colbo
Squad and Mod Squad yeah and uh similar
the different
but different yeah
but bring it back what are the other
headlines that are coming out about it I
had seen the Oprah one there was um
Linda Evangelista shared how she was
like made to take pictures at the age of
16 like inappropriate photos and just
some of the pressure that they right
face as young women in the industry
Evangelista the one who coined to the
term won't get out of bed for less than
ten thousand dollars yes she she's my
queen because I relate to that like I'm
not getting out of bed unless I'm being
paid I'm sure she's addressing that
comment I do want to watch this series I
know look at Apple Like Making Waves
they're like kind of the most irrelevant
streamer in my opinion like they're
behind Discovery plus they're
the only good like thank God someone at
Apple should seriously give their
firstborn child to Jason Sudeikis like
that's the only reason people buy Apple
TV and then once they get it they're
like oh there are other shows that are
like decent shrinking there's some other
people like but like
they came for Ted lasso and maybe they
stayed so and then the Billy eilish
documentary which was like the only
other thing they ever did and that was a
few years ago
um so good for them for like actually
doing something people give a about
I think that's really cool and it's
never too late yeah Linda Evangelista
recall being pressured and taking nude
photos when she was just 16 years old
it's really disgusting which almost made
her give up on modeling
these women like I feel like every
Fashion Week somebody like brings them
out they're kind of like a squad I
wonder if there's like beef between any
of them maybe they'll talk about that in
the documentary yeah I'm sure back in
the day there was but now they're all
like mature because Naomi Campbell has
said like she was like the worst when
she was younger but imagine me like
um one of the most beautiful women in
the world for all of these people like
so successful how do you not become a
monster a Monster yeah no I'm like one
of the ugliest people in the world and I
am a monster so I totally get it me and
Naomi Campbell are like definitely on
the same page yeah especially with
everything they're going through just
makes you put your walls up yeah even
though had they just you know all leaned
on each other it would have been easier
most likely yeah but no it's like
you kind of go into survival mode yeah
itself that does sound good yeah so
those are the past five stories and I
feel good about them I think you were
kind of hard on them you do but I also
can recognize like when you choose the
stories your hardest on yourself like I
feel that way all the time you know when
I choose them
yeah I just feel like there's a couple
of days a year where it's so exciting
where it's like I cannot wait to get
into the Fast Five and I just haven't
had one of those days well there was a
story that we actually didn't recount in
the past five big news that happened
yesterday what that Channing got engaged
oh my God I meant to bring it up at the
beginning of the show thank you so much
everyone knows our favorite girly here
Shannon Ford host of the probably a
podcast Show on TNN
um got engaged yesterday she called us
we were like laying in bed watching
Joanna and she's like look what I'm
wearing and she just uh put her finger
up and like it took me a second to
register I'm like what is she showing me
like
cool you got any jewelry like I was
literally so confused and then I put two
and two together and it's so exciting
excuse me so exciting we're so happy for
Shannon so everybody go with Shannon a
big Mazel Tov from the toast Community
what a good day what a good day and
she's posting so much content like we
need more premium even people are like
shy about like they're big like life
moments like share
Share She's sharing I'm really so happy
for them they're such a cute couple yeah
and it's very appropriate because
yesterday I was telling the story on the
toast uh Ben got into bed and was like
did you hear what happened to Shannon
I'm like what
what happened to Shannon he's like the
DUI I'm like are you talking about
Channing door he was like yeah he's like
using Chen and I thought he was talking
about Shannon Ford now last night I got
into bed and I said did you hear it
happened to Shannon you had heard no I I
told him before the post went up sneak
peek exclusive and he was really happy
we're all really happy for her so
Shannon just kind of big things
happening with all of our TNN hosts
Lauren Elizabeth gave birth you gave
birth
Shannon's engaged
I am you know
skinny that's something that is making
headline news every day about how she
can show her arms now okay so like I did
I do a q a on my Instagram like I try
and do it like every couple of weeks so
I keep up with Peeps and all the
questions are about ozembic and I don't
want to answer every single one about
Islamic but like some of them are good
questions and yesterday literally page
six like ran the uh question somebody
asked about like how I'm showing my arms
now and I used to only wear like short
sleeves or long sleeves I would never
show my arms before in like a tank top
and if I had I known like it would be
written up maybe I would have like
worded it differently but it was just
like a stupid q a like who's
reading these things I have to be much
more careful yeah you know how celebs
feel no it's just like
they have a surprise
and it's worth every penny keep writing
it up girlfriends everybody want an
exclusive interview let me know
um okay should we dive into your
toasters our weekly advice segment we
ciao so for those who don't know
Wednesdays are toast
dear toasters day that's hard to say say
it five times dear toasters day dear
toasters day dear toasters day dear
toasters day dear toasters day well
aren't you just so great
dear toasters day where we do our weekly
advice segment if you want to write into
our submission box you can submit two
ways one of you go to the
toastpodcast.com there's just like a
little box it's totally Anonymous just
write on what's going on with you or you
can email us if it's a little bit longer
at Deer toasters gmail.com we will keep
your names out of our mouths don't worry
it's totally Anonymous and
um if you've written in and you felt
like you know why haven't the girls read
it maybe resubmit and make a little
tighter if it's super long like sorry I
love you but I'm not reading that and
two um maybe like evaluate is your
prompt dumb or boring maybe that's why
we didn't read it
maybe we just had so many great ones
that week maybe
um so dear toasters is brought to you by
Squarespace
so
squarespace.com is the all-in-one
website platform for entrepreneurs to
stand out and succeed online whether
you're just starting out or managing a
growing brand Squarespace makes it easy
to create a beautiful website engage
with your audience and sell anything
from products to content to time all in
one place and all on your own terms so
whatever reason you might be looking for
to start a website whether you have a
side hustle you work in e-commerce you
want to start a blog you're a
photographer you want to showcase your
art
um Squarespace is the place to do it
because you will end up with a
professional looking website that you
did all by yourself it's so easy their
templates make it so easy to design a
really professional looking website and
they have so many fabulous product
features like an asset Library so if you
want to upload organize and access all
your content from one place with the new
asset library at Squarespace you're able
to manage all of your files from one
Central Hub and use them across the
Squarespace platform you can also easily
sell custom merch create passive income
streams that engage your audience and
scale your brand if you're creating an
online store you can sell your products
with a Squarespace online store and
their flexible website templates are so
easy to get started with one of their
professional website templates with
designs for every category and use case
you can customize your look update your
content and add features to fit your
unique needs also if you want to start
doing email campaigns you can drive
sales and engage your audience with
Squarespace email campaigns where you
can easily collect email subscribers on
your site and build connections and
repeat business through regular email
updates so Squarespace has a great
gorgeous stunning uh
offer for you head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain so you get that free
trial on squarespace.com and when you're
ready to launch go to squarespace.com
toast to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain today's episode
is also brought to you by honey love the
best shapewear in my opinion you can't
take my recommendations on everything I
understand that and you know only one
person I feel like shapewear you can
trust your girl there's nothing worse
than suffering with an uncomfortable bra
and thankfully honey love has
revolutionized the bra game upgrade from
traditional bras that use uncomfortable
underwire and bulky Fabrics at trap heat
honey loves bras feature supportive
bonding that eliminate the need for
underwire without sacrificing lift plus
they're made with fabric that's so soft
it feels like second skin you'll
immediately feel and see the difference
it's so next level comfortable you
forget you're wearing it and for a
limited time you can get honey love on
sale get 20 off your entire order with
the exclusive link of honeylove.com
toast you'll be supporting our show
check them out at honeylove.com forward
slash toast I don't even know honey love
made bras I went there for their
shapewear I had like amazing underwear
and then I was like let me what if I
just tried the bra because I'm in this
like new era where I have like all new
bras all new underwear so I went to
Honey Love and their bras are fabulous
because I cannot like most of the time
I'm not wearing a bra with underwire I
just can't it really hurts like my under
like rib area
um and the Honey Love bras are still so
supportive but they're not going to be
digging into your sides they're not
going to be overflowing boob on the side
um like that feeling when you get home
from a long day and you immediately want
to take your bra off you will never
experience that again because their bras
are so comfortable you might even sleep
in them which I definitely do so treat
yourself to the best bras on the market
and save 20 off at honeylove.com toast
use the exclusive link to get 20 off
honeylove.com toast cinched snatched and
lifted it's hot girl season thanks to
Honey love all right dear toasters the
girlies are in need today and I'm ready
it's a lot of moving in content which I
feel like is a is a good place to be but
can be challenging yeah hey girlies my
boyfriend and I have been together for a
little over a year now and we are in
talks are moving in together soon
everything is great except for one huge
problem our animals do not get along
whatsoever I have a cat he has two dogs
the one time we tried to get them
together to meet it ended horribly his
dog attacked my cat so bad to the point
where I had to take an emergency vet
trip at two in the morning needless to
say to say the idea of them living
together seems pretty far-fetched
getting rid of either pets is pretty
much out of the question as we both have
had them for multiple years I genuinely
don't know what to do the idea of
obedience training has been brought up
but as an eight-year-old dog I'm not
sure it would go over well our
relationship is truly amazing and we
want to take the next step but this is
turning into a huge issue okay I'm not a
dog behavioral specialist so I don't
know what can be done but I just think
like you have to get rid of the cat it's
so simple cats are gross well that's
always an option to re-home one of these
animals she said it's actually really
not an option like would you ever read
Bruno to you if if it wasn't working on
my home like really I mean I I would
need to have a really really good reason
but it's not out of the question well
yeah you're just lucky that you have me
yeah but do you have a loved one but
that's the last person yeah that's will
be if nothing else works but you said
they meant one time and it didn't go
well now I don't want to put your cat
continue to put your cat In Harm's Way
But like maybe it takes some time time
and practice and then being around each
other and maybe a dog behavioral
specialist which I am not one so this is
not based in anything but like maybe
it's like they spend five minutes
together then the next day it's 10 like
maybe they have to you know you have to
work together you definitely have to try
a few different things before you make
any big decisions because like you said
you only did it once and it ended poorly
so like maybe was the environment not
calm like I know you know trainers have
all of these different tactics I don't
know exactly what they are but I imagine
that there are slow ways to bring them
together you definitely need to consult
some sort of trainer I don't think you
can do this on your own and you need to
try these like these are two really
important three because he has two dogs
three really important animals in your
life like you have to try but you
shouldn't stall your life like your
progress with your boyfriend moving in
together like being happy you need to
get to work yeah also if those things
don't work or don't exist then think
about re-homing the cat to a loved one
where you can visit the cat all of the
time the thing is like you got to make
it work because if someone's gonna go
it's gonna be the cat because he has two
dogs who get along together so what are
we going to re-home two dogs or one cat
yeah cats are easier to pass off onto a
love definitely so so your cat's on The
Chopping Block so it's like up to you
I feel like Jackie from dog friendly
living might have some tips she has a
really great Instagram account if you
want to check it out at dog friendly
living right she might have you know
solutions for this very problem like do
cats and dogs historically not get along
they fight like cats and dogs right
yikes yikes your cat is on The Chopping
Block just letting you know so like it's
up to you because your man is sitting
pretty being like I'm not gonna get rid
of two dogs no so let's let her figure
it out and I think that there could be
Solutions I'm not hopeless but I'm also
a realist yeah like it's not looking
good but I think there's ways yeah
ways
um all right ready for our next one I
love this question because I literally
like I experienced this firsthand hi
Queens love the show and I could use
some advice we have a friend in our
friend group that always insists on
taking pictures on her phone when we go
out she then severely edits the photos
with facetune and other apps before
sharing them back to us all the fun
memories we have captured in various
pictures are now completely altered with
skinny filters glam makeup Etc I'm all
for her doing whatever she wants to make
herself feel comfortable and confident
on her personal social medias but I
don't want my social media and personal
memories to be flawed and disingenuous
I've even had other friends outside of
our group say that she looks absolutely
nothing like the pictures and that it's
misleading I want to say something but I
also don't want to be an please
send help what's your experience oh my
God I used to be friends with this girl
who like literally would not take a
singular photo on anyone's phone but
hers and like she would literally like
be so strict about whoever was taking
the photo stand up get on your knees
move to left move to the right we take a
million photos group photos and then
like later that week we would get the
one approved photo that we could all
post it's like girl give me the photos
like I don't like this one yeah like
it's it's just it's really annoying
um you have to stop taking pictures with
that girl that's that's the end of or
stop being friends with her start taking
pictures on your own phone yeah and if
she doesn't want unfiltered pictures of
herself out there which she's entitled
yeah then she shouldn't be in the
picture period just start like what does
she she's a boss of you take a picture
on your phone take a picture on your
phone and she gets at like she'll be out
of the photos be like literally just
call it's like it's these people who do
this they think they're so subtle like
no one will notice if I'm always using
my phone and I send them this way I'm
sure nobody's ever called her out but
next time there's a group photo how many
times has the person taking a group
photo whether it's a stranger or person
in the group been given more than one
phone a million times I want your phone
and if she says Let Me Be Like get out
of the picture get out of the picture
you don't have to be in the picture
quote I want this on my phone people say
that all the time for their own reasons
and then she'll be like I'll send it to
you no I want this on my phone yeah I
want this on my phone you need to be a
little bit more aggressive like she's
conquered your group successfully
because you've all laid down your arms
you laid you rolled over and you're
wearing the resistance put up resistance
it really shouldn't be that hard but
just know that you can and the solution
because I don't want anyone to feel
uncomfortable I don't want someone
having pictures of themselves on the
internet that they aren't happy with so
she just needs to leave the photos aside
or maybe put her on the end where we can
crop her yeah yeah but you need to put
up resistance yeah like come on toughen
up yeah I want this on my phone luckily
for me the situation remedied itself
where like I just happened to stop being
friends with that person like nothing
happened was that person an influencer
no yes
um I'm just saying influencers have
their own reasons yeah no this is their
business I was like new to like the
influencer world so I was like I guess
this is what we're doing but then I was
like just like with my friends and I was
like I have no pictures I'm like this is
annoying yeah or you could if
you really like want to get crafty you
could get like a cool new camera and be
like we have to take this on the camera
oh now she's burdening she hasn't the
expense on her back now yeah now I have
to spend money if you want girls a
mental patient you won't go toe-to-toe
with her right no you have to be brave
you have to be brave I wanna see you be
brave I wanna see you I just wanna see
you I wanna see you I wanna see you be
brave
done all right third and final
dear Trudy Trudy and Jax want to start
off by saying security as a religious
YouTube Watcher dear toasters is my
favorite thing ever as in she watches
YouTube religiously or she's a religious
woman
um I'm gonna go with a religious woman
she says I loved your toasters it is my
favorite thing ever it's what gets me
through my hump days I need your advice
my boyfriend and I've been dating for
basically a year at this point and I
haven't had a good night's sleep since
we don't live together but he really
likes sleeping together so we go to bed
together basically every night I
wouldn't mind except he's looking at
religious oh yeah definitely not
religious
um I wouldn't mind except he's the
loudest most disruptive sleeper I've
ever experienced he snores every night
and when he isn't snoring he's a mouth
breather which is just as bad he also
wakes up in the middle of the night will
go on his phone with the brightness full
on bright I don't want to hurt his
feelings but I want to know how I can
politely say I want to start sleeping
apart more so that I can actually get
some rest during the week also I'm
low-key worried that his mouth breathing
breathing is affecting his facial
structure thanks for the help love ya a
Sleepless toaster well this is a
question for turdy because I don't sleep
with a snoring man I do mouth breather
and a wheezer and everything else that
Ben does so I feel like there's a lot of
things going on here like yes if you
started sleeping apart it would fix your
problem but like temporarily in the
future this is the person you're
hopefully going to be sleeping with
every night for the rest of your life so
I think that's just putting the ball
down the field and I don't think that
actually is helpful I agree it's not
about saying I want nights to myself
it's about fixing these things him being
a disruptive sleeper on his phone that's
something you very clearly just say like
listen you're on your phone with full
brightness in the middle of the night it
wakes me up either put your brightness
down go into the other room that's not
negotiable like that's easy to fix
that's easy you just say how you feel
and you're right and how you're feeling
the snoring now I have been there Ben is
both a snorer and a mouth breather and
last night is a perfect example he has a
runny nose oh my God he was so loud like
like I wanted to kill him
um so here's what we do for the snoring
Ben uses Breathe Right Strips they
actually really work then he started to
complain because he used them so much he
got started to get like a little
irritation on his nose I'm like you're
fine and put Aquaphor on it Breathe
Right Strips really work for the story
but also what really helps is and I was
not a believer in like white noise or
like background noise I was not a
Believer but we have a humidifier that's
so loud it drowns everything out like
the city noise when we're here we don't
have our humidifier Ben always puts on
his white noise machine it's not even
White Noise actually I don't like white
noise it's the White Noise app and it's
the air conditioning one like I like a
really loud air conditioner like I'm
sleeping in a vent or something you need
a hatch honestly it drowns everything
out like there are ways to either fix
the snoring or fix your ability to hear
it do both yeah I like we now when we go
to sleep we have so many sound things on
like the big humidifier Ben's thing and
honestly I really like it that's great
yeah I've been using my hatch which I
love and I like to listen to the light
rain yeah they also have brown noise
because sometimes White Noise can be
like a chaotic Brown noise is really
nice so incorporate all these things
into your life there are ways this is
not like a deal breaker it's not the end
of the world you're not gonna have to
sleep in separate beds like millions of
women sleep with men who are loud and
we're finding ways around it also maybe
if you get a noise machine your
boyfriend will sleep deeper and he won't
wake up in the middle of the night and
be on his phone that too and there are
also things you can do in your everyday
life like snoring you're not really
supposed to snore and Ben has lost a lot
of weight he's on his own big too and he
snores significantly I would say 70 less
so
take a shot and shoot up your boyfriend
no don't you give your boyfriend make
what I'm saying like
certain lifestyle changes can help
snoring yes like Ben used to exclusively
sleep on his back and that's when you
snore now he sleeps on his side
sometimes his stomach because he's just
like smaller
so there are things you can do
I think those are a lot of really
helpful tools yeah I feel like I helped
the third girl the most yeah like the
pet girl we were basically like figured
out no and the girl with the photos we
actually gave good advice Joe yeah I
think we helped everyone yeah
um I think we all got great advice I
think we're all really helpful I think
we're all pretty smartless
I think we're all smartless so we're
going to wrap this up tomorrow's episode
stay tuned who knows what's what will be
up tomorrow oh actually I think I said
Taylor Striker I have to text her and
see if she's available and then Friday
Jackson Claude back together but remote
version which is Fabulous video remote
Studio remote studio room video and
audio Yeah Yeah so thank you guys so
much for listening to the toaster
original everybody on YouTube so you're
watching us on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribing this video thumbs
up also available
did we are we are love ya bye good job